do we sat right next to Michael Che in
New York and he's like I got it I got it
and as soon as he said that Jay and I
were like no you don't I got the next
three wrong stick around
gracias to our sponsor Babel very good
day hey do you have travel plans this
summer uh learn to speak like a local
with Babel because with Babel you can
start speaking a new language in three
weeks that's right get started right now
with 55 off your Babel subscription for
our listeners go to babel.com DPT that's
55 off at babel.com DBT spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash DPT rules and
restrictions May apply hey toddies
welcome to another episode of
people Town what did you say short
speeches
I think she like culottes if you pull
them out in there yeah
buddy Steve I didn't know you were a
chef in your off time you look like a
gardening retiree you look like if a
chef decided to become a dishwasher
you're like I got downgraded for dating
the staff yeah yeah like hey hey don't
touch her touch those dishes
officially we met a few months ago on
the uh the patio at the store yeah bar
been a fan of yours ever since yeah big
fan of your I'm a big fan of this
podcast I don't know if you've had like
a huge fan on before before I came to La
there was like a five things I really
want to do when I came to La yeah and
this was it no way I love that beautiful
dude that's so great yeah you were there
with us in the early days when we
stupidly called this Scarborough County
even though we had a sports podcast
called Scarborough country one letter
off we're like aren't we being clever
and people are like is the shoes I hate
sports but I like your show what is it I
hate your show but I like sports it was
like we split our audience in half we
later figured out to call it dumb people
because it's just dumb people the
world's getting Dumber the only way we
can fight it as you know is through
comedy our fans send to the stories and
you know you listen to it from the
beginning when Dan did all three stories
we got a new way that we're doing it now
each of us get to do a story it's great
we have the first one Dan has the first
one well I'm wondering what happened to
the Florida guy the writer oh uh
he no longer writes uh about off the
beat off the beat which is the over
explanations of all the things
why like docked that I try to save for
like live shows yeah so we got a few at
every single time someone plays that
game they're like how were you good at
it could you guess did you know which
was Dan well no I mean I'd be 50 50 but
it was 50 50. I was gonna say what's
your bad these are awesome do we sat
right next to Michael Che in New York
and he's like I got it like I got it and
as soon as he said that Jay and I were
like no you don't I got the next three
wrong also like how could he had to move
up because there's no way like he had to
get more traffic from this podcast
once he busted Robert Kraft he did he
bustered he busted me a part of that
investigative he was The Stranger in
basketball thing he's like all right I'm
done with like writing I can massage my
way out of it I don't have to explain
what pants this story has a happy ending
I don't have to explain what pants are
to people I follow him on musk and uh
everything you just said I have no idea
and uh and I knew he'll still tweet out
but it's always like a very serious news
story yeah and it's not even that much
anymore and I'm like you gotta get back
to yourself come on go back to the the
thing that we do nothing we will be
happier at a live show than Dan saying
ladies and gentlemen we have a great
lady yeah just insane so I hope he
brings that into his other writing you
know he's like a snap wound that's when
something cuts into you yeah blood comes
out blood how many years to cut steaks
blood is not plasma all right are you
ready for this one let's see a story
sent in by Matthew Friedman at not your
average man this dude's sending a bunch
I love him now he's the chibi Carlene of
yeah all right I love this here's the
headline it's all we'd need like if I
handed this headline to you before you
walked on stage you'd be like how long
you want to talk about this wife stabs
husband over explicit photos with
another woman discovers images were of
her younger self yeah hi hey
you remember this
so a my bad doesn't cover it on this one
whoops how dare you how did that it is
so it is sort of a version of like
self-love like she thought this woman
was so hot yeah they couldn't be having
her husband I don't know man was like oh
it's me like I don't know if she thought
it was so hot it was just like no you're
with she thought the woman was young and
beautiful I hope I think she thought the
woman was someone who how did the
husband not look younger in those photos
a woman he kept himself together I bet
you this is a problem in the
relationships he's working out too much
and she looks like [__]
so you don't need to work out that much
you're in the relationship with you're
saying he left them out so she would see
him look at how good I'm just saying
there's an angle of oh I knew it was me
I just didn't want to be reminded yes
and he's and he'll he'll try and sort of
like tiptoe around the set remember when
we went to the Bahamas like it's like
remember look at these old pictures I
found from a trip are these old I can't
remember are these a woman also though
like if you saw yourself naked even if
you got fatter you could be like those
are my nipples yeah like your nipples
don't translate I've told this story on
this podcast
I've told this I was vacationing down in
uh Mexico with my wife this is like 20
18 years ago okay and I'm down there and
I the place was like a weird place that
had not rooms but like Bungalows but
they were not well marked at all my wife
was pregnant at the time she asked me to
go get something at the front desk I go
to get something for her at the front
desk I'm walking back and I like forgot
which one of these Bungalows
you haven't told this her in a long time
I walk in and I see two people just
slapping the old
me in there had it and what are you
doing no I stood there long enough to be
like that's not me that's not my wife
what are you what is who sings that song
this is not my house
yeah do you mask yourself and I was like
wait a minute that's not me then I was
like that's not my wife and then I was
like this is in my room so first you
started standing there watching them
that's not me that's not my wife that's
not my room and then I shut the door and
I left and then the rest and I didn't
get a good look at him I really did you
should have got him I didn't because I
was trying to process it and then the
rest of the trip I was trying to think
who it was what did you see you were
living your own White Lotus
off-white Lotus
beige Lotus I didn't love you like a guy
comes in he's just holding like apple
juice it's sandwiched like having sex
with your wife here oh God I hope one of
them would look
with my mom
I'm with my mom I'm with Daisy we're on
Larchmont and we go into a store and I'm
I drove at the time I was driving my
gray Chevy bolt right yeah
go across the street and I part you
parked that before he's like I parked
that at the store so and I and it was
parked across the street and we came out
of the store we were there for like 25
minutes or a half an hour we come out we
crossed the street and we go and see the
gray bolt and we all get in the car and
sit down and I was like this is not my
water bottle what who put this water
bottle in the back seat two people
[Laughter]
anyway
well this is not my car so once you guys
all jumped out yeah we all jumped out we
were like yeah yeah we all got out and I
was like you've seen a ghost all right
Daniel what happened okay that's crazy
ass a woman stabbed her husband in a
blind rage when she found photos of him
with who she thought was another woman
after failing to realize that the images
were actually of her the woman who was
identified as Lenora R was arrested last
week in Mexico after she stabbed her
husband identified as Juan and multiple
times on his legs and arms did she flee
to Mexico yeah but I want you to
remember this oh I want to kill him but
I just want to hurt him on having sex
with another woman on his phone so
you're right he is in the photos is it
just nudes that like she sent him it's
the two of them them going at it so I
think she was obstructed in some way how
fat did she get before between the
iPhone 13 and 14. that is how drastic of
a haircut yeah
my face Dan is he framing out her face
and this is just like torso a lot of
people on amateur don't worry about
angles but I'll ask you guys if there
were 10 photos of feet would you be able
to pick out which yes I think so too
but I mean woman needs to be stabbed for
not knowing herself
she uh I mean the sound photos Juan
having sex with another woman on his
phone without giving her husband time to
explain why would you began stabbing him
while hurling insults at him is this but
but there's a problem with this
relationship you think she jumps the
conclusion that he's having an affair
with someone right like what has he done
in the ramp up to this that caused her
to be like see the pictures and just
well they obviously don't communicate
well yeah I mean this is he's probably
yelling it was you it was you and she's
like I know I'm the one stabbing you in
the leg too I feel like I could get away
from him the leg is mean the leg that's
mean I don't want you to be able to walk
it was just a stab in the dark for her
when Juan eventually managed to get the
knife from his wife's hands he asked her
what photos she was talking about I love
that he still wants to have a
conversation about this yeah he's like
got the knife
I don't think I don't think what photos
are you talking about is the right
question Oh because yeah because there
are other ones
you tell me which ones you saw the
Dropbox or the Google Drive which fault
did you drop what you got in my hidden
folder because if you're in the hidden
you need to tell me how'd you get that
code what code there's no code for the
Woodland creatures which ones are you
talking about then like Jerry Stein what
ones are you talking about that's one
thing or if he's like which ones are you
talking about then I'm like not even
maybe giving a couple more stats a
couple more in the stomach he then
explained to her that it was nobody but
her and the photos the pictures were
taken years earlier when the couple was
just dating by whom them well I guess
the police were notified of a domestic
dispute after neighbors heard screaming
and shouting inside the couple's home
according to uh dossier police Lenora
didn't recognize herself immediately as
the woman in the images because she was
younger thinner and wearing makeup The
Daily Mail recorded the change of makeup
versus no makeup but that's her excuse
to the police look I was younger I was
thinner I was wearing it up I can't be
expected
anymore wild wild I don't see that go to
like court and everyone's like actually
you know what that doesn't look like you
anymore
she deserves to stab him but there's
enough people on there some people with
makeup that it is night and day oh
completely Pamela Anderson height
without without her makeup and the whole
done up she looked completely different
Kathy Griffin another person who by the
way attractive with and without makeup
100 different Yeah a hundred percent
difference yeah just the way people do
their makeup because now contouring is
like a huge thing that wasn't 15 years
eyes lashes contouring lips it's all
it's a whole other look so maybe let's
give this one looks like James Harden
when you ever see it when they take off
his beard no I'm like a meme
Kyle Kinane without a beard does not
look anything like him I'm like your
beard is like part of it's the shape of
your chin is your beard
what he doesn't look like a Kyle Juan
told cops that he explained to his wife
that he had found the pictures in an old
email and saved them on his phone so
they were newly added to his phone
so so if you were looking in terms of
like when photos they would be most
recently right so she's up in his phone
a lot she's like these are new either
way she would see that they got added in
the last week or two and say and then be
like what are these who are these take a
beat yeah right give someone the
opportunity to at least I mean zero to
stabbing really quickly which again
leads to my thing she's ready to stab
it's a drop of a hat great she's ready
to stab at the drop of a Dropbox zero to
stabbing in 10 seconds
uh Lenora ultimately realized that it
was her in the pictures she was taken
into custody and remains in jail the
case has reportedly been referred to the
public Ministry of the State Attorney
General's office meanwhile Juan was
taking the hospital for treatment
however they did not disclose the extent
of his injuries are they still together
he is expected to recover soon thank God
not no I mean how do you come back from
that I feel like you got a lot of you
know you can get away with a lot of
things in the future you know he came
home late you show one of the stab
wounds
right now this guy has all the capitals
all the marriage Capital right
relationship right now he's got it yeah
he's got to be happy you know because
he's like honey can you go to the store
I don't know can you stab me again oh no
why don't you go to the goddamn store
yeah hopefully it looks the same as the
last time you were there and you don't
drive do you recognize the store that
you've been to over and over again do I
need to draw a map to our house so you
can so much negativity all right that's
Story number one oh my God just take
some time Dan you said it this all so
much dumb stuff could be avoided if you
just take a baby like you know the
there's the kid like you know squash
that beef squash it remember that no
that was like a public service
announcement just this one like squash
it go look it up squash it squash that
beef take a beat take a beat take a
bunch of that beef uh Jay will have our
next story I love it uh and we'll come
back we'll hear uh who's got stuff going
on do you want who do we go first uh
it'll be the two of us yes all right I
love it it's dumb people Town Steve
furious with us we'll be right back
stick around
people town
hey guys welcome back to the show uh we
got a lot of good stuff going on uh Dan
and Steve Dan go first what do you gotta
have uh coming on I have like so many
dates uh I don't have time to run them
all through where can people find them
but go to danielvankirk.com it'll be all
over the East Coast the Midwest and the
South all leading up to 11 11 where I
will be shooting my special eleven okay
make a wish recording my next album both
of those things will be happening go to
danielvankirk.com for those tickets it's
a it's like 25 cities so if you're west
of the Mississippi and you're hearing
this in the next there will be one near
you there will be one near you I would
love to have and you know what I start
out the shows now by asking if any town
he's brought a headline so if you're
hearing this and you want to come to
those shows bring a headline we'll do a
little goofing around and then I'll
bring out the host and we'll kick off
the show I love it Steve uh just check
me out on my Instagram Steve Fury I got
a bunch of shows at The Comedy Store
about four months I'm sure I'm gonna get
the scars on one of them oh yeah so make
sure you guys check that out uh last
third Saturday and fourth Tuesday at The
Comedy Store love it love it love it you
got a story great show yeah I got a
story so good all right are you we'll do
it before I do this are you are you a
Disney guy do you consider yourself a
Disney guy I mean I was for a while I
love Disney I just haven't been in a
couple of years no I'm not at all I love
Disney too but like I think it's because
I love it like I went to Taylor Swift
since we've last seen each other you're
a new man and I will say that was
where's your bracelets uh Daisy my
daughter was like gave gave 35 out got
like 40 back wow and it was great she's
like trading braces with strangers and
so far yeah went to Sofi amazing show
amazing show but the truth of the matter
is I'm not the biggest Taylor Swift fan
and I was just loving watching my kids
love it so I don't know if I'm a Disney
fan I as much as I am this was a fun
experience with these guys I like Disney
a lot well Disney kids Disney World
Disneyland it can get really fun like in
this next story okay I doubt it man gets
drum sentence uh this was sent in by uh
FL free thinker
I already love man gets drunk man gets
drunk at T-Rex Cafe
then unleashes dinosaur-like Rampage at
Disney Springs fighting manager knocking
over child and attempting to bite
sheriff's deputy that's the whole story
headline
I mean that bar tab to get drunk at
Disney had like 2K yeah at least yeah at
least so you're at Disney World too oh
because that's that's where Springs is I
think this is so typical I mean there's
a moment where he is ordering another
one and the kid working behind the thing
who's like in a tricer in a Triceratops
thing
sir you can't have another sorry no I
want to be happy this is the happiest
place
you've already had seven uh my thing is
let me wear your name I hope he pushed
over allowed to take it off one of the
kids on a ride wait nobody pushed over
one of the kids who was too small to get
over like as they were finding out yeah
I can't get on this ride uh here we go
uh a man's evening out at Disney Springs
led to his wild arrest seasoning out
that's not an easy way to go out for
right now I don't I don't remember the
headline do we think he is Solo or with
a family oh wow solo I mean definitely
he's obviously probably getting drunk
but I'm saying like is he there on a
family vacation or is this a lone wolf
or he said to his family you get right
I'm gonna take it over to Disney Springs
yeah all right we'll find out I think
he's a single I think he's Solo solo bye
Steve I think you're right by the time
the night was over the man had fought a
restaurant manager that's enough dude
you had to go through like a Hostess
right so like your server yeah
get to the manager you're too aware of
Mickey himself sir I need you to stop
being violent and then it's like oh here
we go he was responsible for do you now
for knocking over a child uh and then
try to bite the sheriff's deputy who was
going to arrest him the Orange County
You're Gonna Go Go I mean
he went out doing what he loved you just
got arrested what are you doing never
going to Disneyland again
uh all of it was a public spectacle as
the scene happened in front of Disney
guests enjoying their evening at the
popular shopping and restaurants
the November 26th incident so is this
Thanksgiving he's a guy who doesn't have
a family
what are you grateful for shove
um uh incident started after Arnett
Gregory Jr well get how old he is later
he switched his first his first name is
Arnette and his last name is Gregory
yeah Junior his last name is Junior and
Gregory could be his middle name uh
Arnette Gregory Jr of Kent Ohio okay was
cut off from the bar who said that I
said cut off from the bar sir you can't
have any more at the T-Rex Cafe because
he was intoxicated yeah after he fell
asleep at the bar I mean not bothering
anybody hey what's he doing you wake up
and say I'll have another that's you
remember that you still want one how
many sleeping people have you removed
when I used to work at the comics all
the time especially how ladies late
shows in the or just passed out just
passed out in the back sir you gotta
wake up oh the best one was oh I can't
remember the guy's name he passed away
Eric oh whatever this one guy was one of
the best paid regulars we ever had I
think yeah and he would go up real late
at night he passed away in Texas he
crushed so hard that a dude sleeping
woke up clapping
when I was a door guy my favorite thing
was people I would kick out who were
somehow so relieved that I did this
right like they were great like dude
thank you man thank you for getting me
out of here yes I wanted to leave it's
always the friend the friend's always
like thank you for getting this person
out I know I'm sorry but I love the guy
who says thank you because you're just
interacting with him in a nice way
that's all he wanted yeah
and it's just like to you just to you
Dan thank you thank you man you guys are
the you guys there's only one you guys
are allowed to hug people
uh Gregory was asked to leave I'm
assuming he wasn't he was definitely
alone he was asked he didn't take it
well he lunged at the manager and began
acting aggressive right out of asleep uh
after saying a few words anyone want to
guess what words he said it's not listed
but [__] [__] I'll beat your mom up tell
her I'm sorry
I'll show you who's acting goofy
uh kachow uh Gregory left but he was not
done he returned to the restaurant how
many minutes later did he return to said
restaurant after being booted by the
manager I'm gonna say well I feel like
they probably rounded gonna tell me I'll
say five minutes five minutes what are
you gonna say Steve I'm gonna do 25 you
went to go check out a ride
mine was so long came back
I thought it'd be a shift change if you
guys are doing solo writers 45 minutes
get your answers in 45 25 5.
he came back 15 minutes later there he
goes two minutes later and went into the
restaurant's kitchen looking for the
manager well Gregory found the manager
of course all right the manager told us
yeah and another thing he walks into the
kitchen I'll tell you what you can't
sell me Arnett was aggressive and
threatening him and wanting to fight
yeah he as he was walking Arnett out of
the restaurant Arnette stopped in the
dining area and lunged at him again this
time push him in the chest while yelling
and swearing loudly causing a
disturbance while other families were
eating so other families are in here and
they're eating uh don't you think he
just walked in like like Vincent
D'Onofrio in Men In Black yeah when he's
full of bugs like that's just very like
like once he hit the door there were
other families that were like watch this
watch this I think it's hard to get
alcohol at a Disney World though you
know right now there's probably only one
oh there are right so if you are
bringing your family to an area where
there is alcohol you gotta know that
this is an opportunity so rare yeah but
this is is not going to happen in like
Harry Potter World with butter beer yeah
I know that's you can get alcohol there
yeah I just did it yeah I got a shot of
Jameson in my butter beer
yes you go into the three Hogs Head bar
or whatever it is there and then there's
three broomsticks stand through God damn
it it's three three it's Hog's head
three broomsticks no it's not it is the
three brooms there's a hog one too and I
went I took my nephews in there and they
got regulars and I got one got drunk Dan
bed smart and another thing I just
evened out okay it stopped I just put it
like if you were Arnette Gregory junior
you would switch your name around to
Kirk Dan Van which people have done Dan
Van here
so that's my just my genius Alias Kirk
Van Dan yeah that's who you're gonna
start checking into hotels
martial arts expert Kirk Van Damme you
can do the splits on two buses halfway
halfway uh advised one of our uh at one
of the times Arnett pushed the manager
of course he fell back onto a small
child no okay so that's technically on
the manager I know also how small was a
child yeah you gotta have a better like
balance and a better base this guy's
gonna be pushing you get away from small
children uh once outside the restaurant
Arnett pushed him again and then walked
away the manager before you're the
parent of the small child that this
guy's on you take a shot at this yeah
we're at least getting free dinner come
on you pushed a drunk dude and when the
guy doesn't give you a free dinner you
push yeah you joined you join up you
join up with our net and another thing
aren't it I got
I got all of a sudden it turns into an I
am Spartacus situation with Arnett
out in Disney Springs Arnett was soon
intercepted by Orange County Sheriff
Deputy near the Under Armor store we
must protect this house uh the deputy
asked Gregory to go with him to the
front office to keep him away from the
public Gregory F-bomb the deputy
yeah so this is like you understand that
like well now there's a crowd of people
with children watching this we'll bring
the cops in bring the cops in they'll
handle everything and he's ruining
everybody for everybody they are I just
love the way that's written yeah like
one of my current favorite things to
describe is someone [__] like
this dude walks in and starts
[__] everybody yeah like like
starts MF in the whole yeah yeah yeah
like I love that and the fact that this
guy wrote like then he bath bombs them
he dropping f-mobs but you know every
blade of grass at Disneyland is like
taken care of it is manicured in a way
so that your experience is the
experience that they want you this is
like a rogue robot on Westworld that's
right right part of the program get it
away from the other someone has to dump
water on it and short it out get it away
the other robots that really would
probably help him yeah this guy like a
blast of cold water might change we're
just going to drag him up to Splash
Mountain before they do the redo on it
and this is going to sober all right
listen this myself and other Osco
deputies ocso deputies went to place our
net in handcuffs I grabbed his left
wrist began to place it behind his back
at which time Arnett began to tense
brace and pull his arms to the front of
his body attempting to impede us from
placing them in handcuffs while he was
moving his body resisting us he lowered
his head towards my left arm as if he
was going to bite me because he said I'm
going to bite you I don't you wonder
what he sang the whole time because
you've dealt with this too yeah the
things people say when you're needing to
move them like there's weird
non-sequiturs and like this is what I
fought against my whole life
it's hotter here's why it happened
here's why it happened here's why it
happened you're like what happened this
is what's happening here that's why it
happened uh I gave a very give it to her
don't give it to her don't give it to us
you don't own my keys what are you
talking about it's hotter than I thought
I gave loud clear verbal command do not
bite me the deputy wrote in his report
did you learn interesting he's talking
to a dog yeah
disturbance
are you gonna bite fast or slow slow so
he was taken into custody There Was You
know I began to yell loudly and cursed
causing several people to stop what they
were doing and stare at us like I said
pictures crowd of families around now
this is more entertaining than
entertaining than the line for the
Matterhorn oh yeah right I just hope
they tied one of those balloons inside a
balloon to him yeah that's my favorite
Disney dumb thing but out front of an
Under Armor too he's probably the only
only reason they have dredging up
business
during my interaction with Arnett I
detected a strong odor of alcohol of
course employees coming from in
bloodshot watery eyes he had a hard time
walking and needed assistance our neck
Gregor was arrested and charged with a
third degree felony count of battery on
a law enforcement officer two
misdemeanors for battery and resistant
officer without violence although he was
a little violent uh and he pleaded now
he listened to the completed not guilty
why would anyone plead not guilty in
that scenario a million 12 Donald
duckries exactly right his arraignment
is uh hearing is scheduled for January
26th orange Circuit Court he should I
think Disneyland should have its own
Court yeah well they have their own jail
but it's like a guy dressed in a wizard
outfit welcome to the Disney Cars yeah
there's a whole tutorial
so long
it's pretty good that would be good how
old he is
we have reached the decision 12 Angry
dwarves 12 Angry dwarves would be
amazing I don't like the look on his
face uh do we get together we do get
tested this is we're going to close this
out to your house Cafe how old is a man
who went to a TRX Cafe pushed over a man
that knocked over a child and continued
to push him in the thing refuse to get
handcuffed and tried to bite the cops
what is what what age of a man
one of you is close but not all the way
there okay Arnette Gregory junior
like Gregory Abbott Jr Arnett gravity
he's been shaken down of Kent Ohio
50 years old
the right direction Thrice divorced
divorce taking it ran you take the final
one when we come back Randy's gonna
bring some 50 years old
used to sound old that's a year younger
though no no it's not old it's just too
it's just old to be doing all that [__]
it's old to be falling asleep at the
T-Rex Cafe and way too old to be at
Disney World
on Thanksgiving like that's old old for
that okay if you were gonna that's I
don't got a lot of chances yeah 50. you
knew you were gonna get drunk that day
yeah you knew it why the T-Rex Cafe
people like what's your favorite bar
you're like T-Rex T-Rex
at downtown no that's at Disney Springs
yeah I want to be around as many
families as I like to spend 140 just to
get into a place 50 you need to be
getting you need a higher level you need
to be getting drunk at Epcot you need to
do it like the Tour of the World getting
hit yeah
maybe or something beers around the
world so when we come back we'll do
we'll let people know what we have going
on and I have a story about and I I've
read this story several times and I
don't know who I'm the most mad at but
it is someone doing a really nice thing
but at the same time just the
who's Randy mad at at this point I'll
check in with you it's a short story but
it's a good one and it's just so crazy
and it happens at a McDonald's these
dumb people Town Steve Fury is with us
we'll be right back
[Music]
podcast Jay do you know what that means
are you enjoying my podcast very good
thank you Babble do you know what it
means stop asking us a question you know
what it means yes I do it means are you
enjoying my podcast sure but what do you
know
this is Babel folks and it's teaching us
how to how to speak other languages very
quickly and only a short period of time
so the best way to do it Dan as you know
is to live amongst people and you um
I've lived in other countries lived in
Israel we learned how to speak second
best way to do it is through Babel it is
so simple I got the battle not everybody
can go travel just yeah hey I'm gonna go
live in Barcelona you're not gonna do
that so what I did is I downloaded the
Babel app on my phone and before we went
to Italy before I went to Italy and now
any so now I still have learned it
because I'm like I still want to
continue to learn because I'm going to
go back to Italy but like when I'm
walking anywhere if I'm walking the dog
I'll just put it on and just do all the
exercises they're like little games it's
so fun and after you complete these
little lessons which again are like fun
little games it's almost like you don't
realize that you're learning so much so
quickly I was also feeling like I was
learning like because you'll yeah I know
that sounds so novel I know like for me
I was like oh I know what this is now
and it's easy and fun and the way that
you can hear it and interactive and then
you speak it back to it so you're
actually they figured everything out
they've actually made it really fun and
you come away with it saying okay I
understand a lot more so I say Emily
grazi and we're hey nice thank you very
much uh so this summer you can start you
can start learning a new language with
Babel and it works instead of paying
hundreds of dollars for a private tutor
or fooling yourself with language apps
that are a little more than games
babbles quick 10-minute lessons are
designed by over 150 language experts to
help you start speaking so I got it as
little as three weeks I got a deal for
our listeners okay for our listeners
it's limited time deal for our listeners
to get you started right now get 55 off
your Babel subscription but only for our
listeners at babel.com DPT that's 55 off
at babel.com
spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash DPT rules
restrictiones May apply wish I knew what
apply was in Spanish but you'll get
there I'll get there thank you Babble
I'll get there enjoy it
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we take us home Jay tell us uh
Ann Arbor Michigan uh I don't know when
this is dropping but I'm assuming it
will drop before then September 8th and
9th we're going to be in your damn City
doing shows it's UNLV football weekend
Randy's daughter is going to be up at
Michigan Ann Arbor comedy showcase one
of our favorite clubs Daniel's gonna get
in there and do some time there at some
point in the uh Jeff Tice the amazing
job tonight October October Dan will be
there Jeff Tice will be with us it's
gonna be super fun uh also that we have
two target shows in uh September how did
one go so good last night it was so much
fun we were like electric electric like
the energy was Tom Papa did our show and
then he went down in the original room
he tried one of the jokes and it worked
I love it he really yeah tried the tag
office that show's going so well that
they may end up giving you the
opportunity to move it but I think it's
perfect for the belly so we're like
trying to we're we're like where do we
do it so we we're doing it Largo too
that's great too but I'm just saying as
far as the store goes feels so good I
know there's something about being in
that room and you know the belly room is
just but when it's so the belly room is
like three there's three levels to it to
me it's it's empty and it's a little sad
because yeah then it's all the seats are
kind of full but the energy is just it's
a small room we've been in there for
those shows then there's the energy of
what we would call maybe when the roast
battle was at its height yeah or when
when you can't even move on the side
right and there's got people standing in
that back by the box come upstairs in
the back and they're looking in and then
the balcony is like all you know fill
and people are people are talking it's
like there's just this energy going back
and forth that's what it was last night
Bob the drag queen from uh real Paul and
everything was on the show Crush crushed
crush crush but like Neil Brennan was
just uh and Roy was incredible he just
amazing he's going to be on this show
it's September 13th September 13th that
comedy store in the belly room who's
already on that show uh Ian Carmel Greg
Fitzsimmons Jamie Lee Melissa via Senor
maybe Natasha and maybe eddiepie maybe
Ed pepitone so killer lineups and then
at Largo on the 18th of September which
is a Monday night we're gonna have a
Kumail Patton an unannounced special
guest and we're working on maybe one or
two others so all that is uh
supersclouds.com all those dates we'll
put them on there uh and I'm going to
take you home with this story which
you're gonna just did various points in
this story who does Randy think is the S
where who am I mad at okay okay and it's
so it's really a study I love that it's
a short one but you still take multiple
turns I mean I I kind of went I think
it's impressive sent in by we talking uh
by we talking about practice at not a
game underscore three I love this guy
here's the headline McDonald's customer
mistakenly given bag containing lots of
cash instead of food
so if you're not mad at anybody yet that
happens sure I guess if you were the
manager you'd be does it happen Dan does
it happen unless I'd be mad at the guys
like uh I ordered a biscuit what is this
[__] okay if someone hands you a bag of
money at McDonald's you drive the FI
healing out you can peel out and you go
over there before I finish reading and
you get the pub Burger on the pretzel
okay a customer identified as Josiah
Vargas which to me that's not his name
is that his name you're just we're gonna
identify he's like an Amish cartel
member
Josiah Vargas he's on a rum Springer
by the way rum Springer how is there not
a beer called rum Springer with yeah and
with the Amish guys
when you want to go off the rails I want
to have when you're having 41. the one
to have when you're at Disneyland and
you're alone and it's Thanksgiving I'm
sure you want to forget you have a
family
rum Springer is like Jagermeister and
beer right it should just be like
what's the one car bomb that you drop is
that a Jagermeister into a beer well I
mean there's a boy but then also an
Irish Car Bomb Irish Car Bomb is
dropping more name what is it uh it's a
half a shot of Jameson and a half a shot
of Bailey's dropped into it into a glass
of Guinness I also love the idea of like
not saying I got drunk last night but
then I just went on rung Springer real
quick I dabbled in the wrong screen I
went on a cricket sound more babe I was
texting you all night I was texting you
all night also inviting people
on Saturday
a quick rum Springer
also a nooner we can do an afternoon
you trying something that's
the customer identified as Josiah Vargas
I'm mad at am I mad at them now for
identifying and not giving his name or
making me forget Disney received
I'm gonna just oh do we guess the money
it's not they don't say the amount okay
but they say a group General yeah so do
you guys have thousands of thousands of
dollars what do you think hundreds
hundreds of dollars what do you think it
is I like 1500 1500 uh get your answers
in town is I know this is a general one
receive thousands of dollars very good
of cash instead of what do you think he
ordered oh well if he's U2 a holes he
got Nuggets how many chicken nuggets do
you think you could eat in one sitting
from about to put them down 40 before
40. God damn it this guy too I've never
done 40 days I've never done 40. I said
you think you can I said I easily can I
said I can do 60. I could easily do six
now I got the taste on those things
change though once you hit like 30 it's
like you're eating pennies like
something happened what's your third eye
what's your third eye opens up once
you're like just jonesing off a [__]
your hands why does everything look
great I don't dislike them but I think I
could only eat like seven and I'd be
like I can't this is so our friend gar
right now
he was in he was dating his now wife at
the time was he was dating her he went
to Syracuse and she uh went to Alabama
so he's down in Alabama at a football
game and he's with her and all of her
friends in an Alabama football game and
they're all dipping and he had never
dipped before he's like give me that and
he takes like a huge thing of dip and he
what's it in his lip and he's like after
like I don't know two minutes of it
being in his mouth and like the
fiberglass cuts inside of your thing and
then the juice comes in he's like he's
like he started he's like I started
shaking back and forth he was going like
this and then he just like collapsed
over and like fell over he's like it
literally not and the room was spinning
and it was just like insane he's like it
was insane that's what I imagine like
the 4 40th McNuggets going in they also
have fiberglass yeah we should do a
McNugget eating contest okay I can't uh
so you say McNuggets what do you say you
ordered uh I said Mick what's the
sandwich
the breakfast sandwich
I'm gonna go he was a double like two
double cheeseburgers okay I haven't had
a Big Mac in like 50 years all right so
instead in 50 years you have 40 years
the thousand thousand cash instead of
the sausage McMuffin I was close he
ordered according to a video he posted
on tickets Vargas has seen the video
pulling he's seeing the video pulling
small plastic bags of cash so you don't
post the video of you getting money
who am I mad at you keep that quiet you
drive away and you go spend it on
something you were never gonna spend
money on No Country for Old Men not
teach us anything dude
quicker if the guy's just going on live
everyone
hey Anton sugars like I saw your posts
Stephen I'm gonna tell you right now you
get let's say you get two thousand
dollars at McDonald's unexpectedly and
you're like I can't even deposit this
money no you can go drive somewhere
right away what do you buy right away
for in the 2000 for 2K where do you go
and what do you buy I have to get rid of
it yeah you got to go shoot I might
treat my boys to an Omakase
let's get something insane not many
people let's go crazy dinner yeah all
sake flights you're like I want to treat
myself yes you want to include people
that's why I love you what do you do
that's a great call two grand so I'm
currently in the market for a new like I
want like a mid-century entertainment
center thing under my TV so I probably
would try to just go buy one of those
but I like and experience better so I
think I'd probably call up like you guys
and be like who wants to go to this day
spa and I got everything day spa or
dantanas and let's just light it up I
think you got to get something that goes
away that I can't return yeah no it's
like in the wind that's an experience
put any sort order plastic surgery that
you really want on as many credit cards
as you can they will never take your
nose away that's right like what are
they gonna [__] do right that's true
Vargas and you're hopefully if you did
for the right reasons very happy yeah
yes Vargas is seen in the video pulling
small plastic bags of cash out in the
McDonald's bags he says what is this why
would they do this
and he wonders what he should do with
the bag of money why would you guys do
this to me you know how bad I want this
money he asked during the clip
[Music]
the wiener schnitzel at the end of my
block got raided the guy would sell
cocaine out of a wiener sorry about the
one I make Magnolia and no no this one
was when I was in Sacramento it was
right down our block it was like what
what a night you know you're just eating
Wienerschnitzel [__] hot dogs
and you're either high or drunk so
you're yourself are like oh [__] oh [__]
oh God is this happening are you seeing
this so he although he admits he was
tempted to keep it
Vargas is eventually seeing the video
walking back into the McDonald's to
return the cash so he is a good guy now
I'm mad at whoever put multiple bags
yeah what do you think the reasoning
behind that yeah so this is this is what
I think yeah yeah I think you're right I
think someone had it
maybe the money maybe they were dealing
drugs out of McDonald's they had it in a
bag at work and it was sitting low and
someone didn't realize or picked it up
what is this I think this is their order
and just picked up a bag and handled I
bet like it was the his drug dealer the
guy above him was behind the McMuffin
guy oh okay so you know then he goes up
and then he gives McMuffin
either way someone on that staff didn't
show up for a work that accident like
somebody was like I can't ever I'm never
going back there again I found have you
guys found Money free ketchup for life I
found like 20 bucks before 20. I found
in there's over on the West Side there's
a Trader Joe's and a Walgreens they
share like yeah building and there's a
little foyer in between them and I found
a hundred dollar bill on the ground and
I did stand there for like with it long
enough to be like someone's gonna
realize they lost this money yeah and
then I had to go into the Walgreens and
I said hey if anybody says they come in
here while I'm getting my stuff whatever
look for money let me know I didn't tell
them what it was obviously good but I
figured a hundred bucks some someone's
freaking out especially near a grocery
store like somebody's freaking you don't
know they might need that right also but
if I got handed Stacks I I would hope
drive and just was like also if I return
it I'm only returning 50 right yeah
that's all you found yeah that's all I
found yeah it was in the wind so I want
you to hear this McDonald's employees
could be heard on the video expressing
their gratitude and relief when you turn
the money wait this was their money well
if they were if because you know
sometimes they do have once you get to a
certain amount of money or a certain
point that you have to go make a bank
drop so you think McDonald's bags yeah
that's what I'm saying they put it in a
McDonald's bag and like they're bringing
in the cross
it's like the Big Mac too it looks like
you're delivering it to the this could
have been the University of Tennessee
trying to land a recruiter right this
could be recruit money this is part of
the manabelle documentary oh my God look
at that an employee said I really want
to give you a hug if I only knew your
real name just sure yeah Vargas then
walked outside the store and said the
employees were crying as they hugged him
and thought because they were going to
lose their jobs maybe the customer was
rewarded we'll get on this he was
rewarded how much
might be both
I'm gonna say they gave him
burgers for the year burgers for the
year what do you think 500 to McDonald's
and McDonald's
500 to and one night with Grimace
and then cut down it's actually maybe
two but if you had a night with Grandma
if you rolled up to The Comedy Store
with Christmas to do whatever you want
whatever you want do whatever you want
whatever you want with Grimace one night
they would give new name to the give new
meaning to the name Stephen Fury yeah
wait so how much how much do you think
it was you say 500 in McDonald's box and
that's and 500 I'd say a year of burgers
your Burgers I'd be like when McDonald's
Monopoly comes back hook me up with a
park there you go
documentary amazing yeah Tom Segura made
that documentary his producers yeah
really yeah amazing all right so what do
you think I don't know I actually saw
two and I don't want to shoot okay so
then all right are you ready man you
ready only you two are guessing right
now okay he was rewarded with two
hundred dollars and free McDonald's for
a month a month that is is that enough I
asked well see how he was so annoyed at
getting the money I feel like that's
more than he even wanted he deserved it
doesn't sound like corporate money to me
nope it feels like you're throwing me
money back that's McDonald's that's no
that's not McDonald's you got to go
through so many things
between tears are like give them 200.
just don't do it on Tick Tock yeah yeah
exactly and don't Focus [__] don't post
this [__] you get 200 and we'll shut up
and don't talk for a month but you can
only come in here on Thursdays when
Jeanette and I are and here's what you
do you go into the women's bathroom you
say you order it yeah you say it into
the vent and then you walk behind the
store at the dumpster and I bring it out
to you shut the [__] up
if nobody answers that's on you I came
at the wrong time yes we know you
returned our bags of cash but I will
throw it over the side with all the
dirty things and that's how you're going
to get you can also show up here every
night at 11 57 that's when we take out
what we couldn't sell or was a mess up
order if you get us before we get to the
dumpster it's yours you know about the
fact that there is now cash in bags of
McDonald's so I'm gonna need you to make
a drop of some white powder across town
right that would be the greatest let me
ask you yeah guys what would make you
happy in this scenario yes you give the
money back and they have a thousand
dollars in free McDonald's for a year
but that's fair thousand dollars for
going through for this thing for you
giving it back also for us too because
as much as you can be on the road
whether it's an airport or whatever and
be like oh because their breakfast to me
is my favorite fast food breakfast can I
tell you Dan I recently had it and I
liked it because I my son hadn't had
breakfast and I was yeah before
basketball we would make use of that
we're over there and I'm like it's good
it's it's breakfast burrito is the best
I think I mean why because it's just got
that just the right amount of racism and
a homophobia it's just
the sauce have you tried the homophobia
hash browns they're unbelievable
um unless Chick-fil-A wants to sponsor
our show in which case we will edit that
out uh there you go that's show you guys
what a crazy great story great so fun
Stephen Fury thank you guys so much for
giving me thanks for finally being on
the show I love bringing a fan on the
shows so fun but you're a great comment
wait where should people follow you at
Scuba Steve Fury scuba like you're
diving not like uh Scooby-Doo Steve Fury
there you go guys we love you so much
and oh [__] we got to get back to work
bye
town
[Music]